Oh let that take out that Tiger I'm
gonna be the Lord of it I'm Ryan Graham
I've been dancing since I was a kid of
course I'm Dominican so the whole family
dances you know side side by cha-cha
meeting gets mostly like Latin dancing I
grew up dancing and stuff too like I was
always like first want to be on the
dance floor my mommy's taking to the
bike shop and I would be like in there
doing a little dance for your friends I
was that kid you would thank you I can
say that well you do thanks it now you
were driving
yeah we're dragged I've definitely
incorporated a lot of data to my drag so
today with the improvers amateur my
amateur is naturally good there's gonna
be a tough one to decipher if he's a new
guy right now amateur could mean so many
things cuz amateur can mean idle things
for a company yeah really good at dance
like I do YouTube or or or Instagram so
it could be really tough I think we got
it you ready to go to go I'm ready so
let's bring in the dancers oh hi oh my
god oh my god oh that's scary I didn't
realize that the Grim Reaper was here I
we see you we're gonna decide which one
is the pro who is the amateur this is a
lot of mystery right there's a lot of
mystery off the bat I'm guessing only
because this looks more difficult I'm
gonna guess that you or probably
professional dancer cuz they're trying
to throw us off yeah I would say the
same too because you have dubs nica's
okay I won't even work oh maybe it's
wearing that song no all right let's see
what happens se alright dancers I want a
nice clean dance
no I poke in no breaks I mean you can
breakdance but don't break anything
when have you call it in the air heads
or tails
it is like a there's nothing to what I
say
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
I feel like I know who the pro is you do
the fashion throw you off a little bit
but the way that she was moving it was
the speed that she was doing it so
sometimes she'll go fast in the slowdown
there's all about rhythm so she had that
muscle memory that she's done this
before I think you were very good you're
really really great like that technique
the movement was yeah I feel like we
couldn't see the footwork from the Grim
Reaper and I feel like there was
something hidden under this skirt we
there was a lot of legwork that we
didn't see ready Hey
go I think what did you do I say I say
the cop is probe and the Grim Reaper is
damage I ended up switching mine I did
the cop being the pro and the Grim
Reaper being amateur to you so we we
think we got it right now if we're gonna
go ahead and do another round just in
case round 2 fight
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay
okay wait
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so the Grim Reaper really brought it he
brought it is like that's like the first
thing was like a teaser a little taste
both of you easily could be pro if yeah
my answer stays the same
just because just huh movie whom omens
are very snappy I think I'm gonna switch
you're gonna switch because I think
they're both really good they both
really good what the energy the Grim
Reaper bra makes a like you know I think
he's gonna I need to what's going on
yeah he's like I'm not gonna let I'm not
gonna let someone show me up yeah I'm
gonna head Grim Reaper's the pro and the
amateur or the amateur to cop hi I'm
Tina I'm actually the amateur dancer
[Music]
emo and lfg yeah thanks Gilly and I'm
the pro dancer yeah I knew it I I do
dance this dance style freestyle with
shuffle and I've gone like borrow a
couple times so I'm pretty sure that it
was part to dance in that fat suit and
also in that Grim Reaper both of you are
incredible dancers Wow yeah
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]